- What up, YouTube?
Super excited for this
unique video episode.
This is the Biz Dev Barter
of Empathy Wine episode.
The last 48, 72 hours
have been remarkable.
I haven't bartered my time in a long time.
My number one goal in life
is to not have to ever barter
the thing that I value
the most, which is my time
and access to me.
However, once in a while,
you have a big project.
Empathy Wines, maybe, DRock,
you can edit and superimpose it right here
(ding)
But on my birthday a couple of weeks ago,
I announced empathywines.com, my winery.
The best $40 wine made for $20
is kind of how I thought about it.
Red, white, and rose.
And over the last 72 hours, John Troutman
and Nate and Nora and
the team at Empathy Wines
have been doing the barter thing
and it's been remarkable.
And it's really going well.
And then I realized, huh.
I haven't told everybody about it.
And so I'm like, huh.
I haven't done anything
for YouTube about this.
Let's do the right thing by YouTube.
A, because I want to make
sure they get the at-bats.
B, because I have five or
six more packages in me.
So, go to the URL that's
popped up right now.
Go to that URL.
Submit your offer.
In a world where I get
10,000 emails a month
of like, how do I get 30 minutes with you?
Or, how do I get a five-minute FaceTime?
Or, how do I get a full day?
Or, how can I shadow the team?
We are available for a couple more hours
before I feel good about
how much wine has been sold,
which is getting very close.
And so, YouTube, you get the last at-bat
at the barter offers for Empathy Wines.
Make sure you read the information.
I'm not giving you 10 minutes
of my time for three cases.
This is big girl, big boy stuff.
So for all the people out there
that are ready to take the
next step in their business
or their life,
and feel like there's a worthwhile trade
and they can take the wine and donate it,
or use it as corporate gifts or drink it.
This is definitely
more in the 50, 60, 70, 80, 200 case game.
Real bucks.
But you'll get all the
details in the URL link
in the information here.
Gary Vee team,
please put the URL in
the comments and pin it.
D-Rock, edit it like a son of a bitch.
- You son of a bitch.
- Have the best day ever, YouTube.
Thank you so much for watching my content.
Appreciate this right hook.
But hopefully you get the right hook back,
because I think the reason
you can tell my energy is awesome,
is I love one plus one
equals three, right?
I get to sell 50, 200,
300 cases when I need to,
because this is a big project
I want to get out there,
and people are getting
something they can't get,
which is me.
Or a free ticket to Four Ds, in theory,
because they were about to get anyway.
You'll see, you'll see on the page.
Thank you.
(music)